Hello friends of AI boardroom drama the
story around the firing of open AI CEO
Sam Altman has had a few twists and
turns since we've last time looked into
this and mind you that was yesterday if
you're not exactly up to speed with the
lore in this universe here Greg Brockman
himself the chairman of the board of
open AI or former chairman is detailing
the key events right here last night Sam
got a text from Ilia that's Elia sser
asking to talk at noon Friday Sam joined
the Google meet and the whole board
except Greg was there Greg here being
Greg Brookman himself Elia told Sam he
was being fired and that the news was
going out very soon at 12:19 Greg you
know the person recounting here got a
text from Elia asking for a quick call
at 12:23 Ilia sent a Google meet link
Greg was told that that he was being
removed from the board but would retain
his role at the company and that Sam had
been fired and at that time open AI
published a blog post uh detailing all
of this and that's when the rest of us
knew so this was a behind the doors deal
followed by a very quick sweep also none
of the investors were informed Microsoft
wasn't informed and so on so Sam Alman
fired Greg Brockman after that quit one
of the big questions was what is the
reason for this very unusual happening
the reason given that Sam Alton was
being fired was that he was quote not
consistently candid in his
Communications with the board hindering
its ability to exercise its
responsibilities a lot of people are
speculating that there was a concern
about AI safety and different directions
of the company and how fast it should be
pushed towards
commercialization but also there is a
different hypothesis popping up namely
that Sam Alman was investing and pulling
up startups into the realm of AI
Hardware to be in in a less dependence
from Chip makers like Nvidia or
suppliers like Microsoft so to
essentially make their own Hardware
which would mean Sam Alman would control
these startups or these companies which
would mean that he himself had much more
power over open AI because as of now he
as you can see he can be fired quite
easily and the hypothesis is that that
he did not disclose that properly that
he was doing all of these things on the
side and therefore uh the board may have
sacked him again this is an an
allegation these are early reports and
Scoops and people close to The Happening
told us types of things so none of this
is as yet confirmed open AI themselves
specifically the chief operating officer
has released a memo saying that the
firing was not made in response to
malfeasance or anything related to our
financial business safety or security
and privacy practices this was a
breakdown in communication between Sam
and the board so this is an internal
memo essentially confirming that there
was some things that Sam may have not
disclosed to the board to their
satisfaction essentially saying that the
money is fine we're fine everything's
fine it's just that he didn't you know
he kind of wasn't too honest which as we
all know even though this is an internal
memo in no way does it mean that this is
the truth this is simply the stated
reason or I mean it doesn't even give a
reason it's kind of very whooshy if you
want to read the full memo uh axio has
an article uh detailing what the memo
says it's essentially saying
everything's fine Sam is gone due to
this and we will continue we're going
forward yay Yao open AI let's go some
fallouts from this open ai's $86 billion
share sale that was planned for as early
as next month is now in Jeopardy so they
were supposed to sell employee shares
employees could sell their shares make a
bit of cash of of it price tag on that
will change now that Sam Alman and a few
other key employees have left other than
employees were shareholders who wanted
to sell for a nice price who may be even
more upset is uh Microsoft specifically
SAA nadela reportedly Furious Furious
following alman's dramatic departure
from open AI which is understandable
probably Alman among open AI leadership
was the most into commercialization of
what they're doing and the most in favor
of taking Microsoft money to grow fast
and so on at least that's what we can
see from the outside and yeah therefore
Microsoft who's hedged a lot of money on
open ai's success especially their
commercial success and product success
is not super happy and so it comes that
news are coming out that Alman is
planning a new AI Venture apparently he
has had a gathering with open AI
employees former and current open AI
employees is at his house and is already
planning a new business who knows if
Microsoft will go along with that on the
other hand the open AI board is urged by
Microsoft and investors to restore
Altman to open AI Alman reportedly is
ambivalent so saying like me I don't
really care uh I can return but I can
also not return that's quite a sigma
move I have to say and then shortly
after that the news saying open AI board
in discuss iions with Sam Alman
returning as a CEO and an update that we
get in this article here saying a source
closed to Alman says the board had
agreed in principle to resign and to
allow Alman and Brockman to return but
since has since waffled missing a key
5:00 pm. deadline by which many open AI
staffers were set to resign if Alman
decides to leave and start a new company
these staffers would assuredly go with
him people familiar with the situation
close to the source whatever that means
saying the discussions are around Alman
returning and the board leaving so that
confirms the previous report that if
Alman actually returns then he would
supposedly have a bit more leeway to
make decisions and obviously would not
want to work under a board that had
tried to fire him or that did fire him
in sort of a a backro deal making from
the Microsoft perspective again these
are a source told Forbes uh making the
Playbook is straightforward make open AI
New Management uh under acting CEO Mira
morati and the remaining board accept
that their situation was untenable
through a combination of mass Revolt by
senior researchers withheld cloud
computing credits from Microsoft and a
potential lawsuit from investors facing
such a combination the thinking is that
management would have to accept Alman
back likely leading to the subsequent
departure of those belief to have pushed
for alman's removal including co-founder
ilas sskk and board director Adam
D'Angelo CEO of Kora so the investors
are going into pressure mode including
withholding cloud computing credits and
another tweet here from Simeon copying
from a Bloomberg article that details
more on the nature of alman's dealings
with other startups or other companies
Alman has been looking to raise tens of
billions of dollars from Middle Eastern
sovereign weal funds to create an AI
chipped startup to compete with
processors made by Nvidia according to a
person with knowledge of the investment
proposal Alman was courting soft Bank
chairman masi masayoshi son for a
multi-billion dollar investment with a
new company to make AI oriented Hardware
in partnership with former Apple
designer Johnny I in turn open AI
employees are sending each other hearts
on Twitter quote tweeting each other
with hearts hearts lots of hearts lots
of hearts for Sam Altman in related news
K AI is a new paris-based nonprofit AI
lab that has a lot of backing and a lot
of big names associated with it saying
they're starting with almost 300 million
EUR of philanthropic support and having
people such as Yan laah on their
advisory boards could this be the new
open AI who knows speaking of yan laa
meta according to the verge disbanded
its response responsible AI team So Meta
dividing up responsible AI into just
individual people who are joining other
teams I don't know exactly if this is
just a restructuring or if the age of
dedicated responsible AI is over and is
more integrated into product teams and
into research teams themselves so who
knows uh everything is up in the air
will definitely continue to closely
monitor the situation around open Ai and
surrounding happenings if Altman comes
back it's going to probably be quite a
different open AI a even more producty
open AI if he doesn't come back
supposedly it's going to be a bit more
of a closed off and uh researchy and
effective alter open AI but all of these
things are just speculations we're
excited to see what happens and we'll
keep on it see you around